parts of California have been
transformed into Winter Wonderland a
white blanket of snow is covering the
slopes of the U.S State's Northern
regions
some areas have received as much as 16
meters of snow lived here in Christmas
Valley for over 40 years we're having a
record snow this year over 55 feet of
snow here at our home and we're all
dealing with it it's been a fun winter
and now spring
decades old snow records have been
broken in California this year causing
power outages stranding people and
burying homes under huge snowfall
[Applause]
people in South Lake Tahoe have been
shoveling snow from their driveways and
rooftops for the past three months so
this year our biggest challenge has been
trying to keep the snow off the roofs
obviously with over 50 feet of snow it's
thousands of pounds of weight on our
roofs some of these roofs are collapsing
and having issues so we've all been very
very busy trying to keep the snow off
our roofs and off of our walkways while
skiers will enjoy an extended season on
the slopes the unusual and
record-breaking Long Winter in
California has left some anticipating
sunnier days and warmer weather
but they may have to wait a while more
snows in the forecast for the greater
Lake Tahoe area